single now I am single enjoying that I
have think they fit yeah yeah nelly
furtado on a British talk-show today
called loose women any angle and lungs
on traffic the very private singer
rarely opens up about her relationship
with husband gentle cats alone but today
she reveals that their marriage is done
come on hair needs to update my
Wikipedia it's not helping my dating
life Nelly surprise announcement her
Wikipedia page has been updated and
states that she and Mo split last summer
after eight years of marriage the pair
met back in 2006 at the peak of Nellie's
career demo served as a sound engineer
on her third studio album blue two years
after that Nelly
exclusively broke the news to our former
reporter Kim Jeon no one's really clear
on the fact are you oh you know are you
a married woman how's Lightman oh yeah
we didn't read out married uh July 19th
and summer I love it yeah it's a nice
space you know it's a nice space of my
life
now that bad phase of her life is over
Nellie's focused on making music
just last month she told Ross she had to
dig deep inside to find inspiration for
her latest album this is super
personally yes yeah super personal okay
[Music]
what is this record about I took some
time I took some time to think it took
some time to live tried to find the joy
again I was busy for a really long time